Doug good morning what's on your mind
first of all you know I love you but
second of all you know you realize
you're criticizing trout for being
exactly what Derek Jeter was I mean I I
know because he's an angel and I grew up
an angel fan that you haven't seen him
play but he plays with the exact right
amount of energy and enthusiasm that
you're saying that that judge has judges
a judges a terrible interview Jeter was
a terrible interview now they're big on
social media it's the only difference is
baseball has changed that's it is that
why actually baby baseball hasn't
changes that we've changed in terms of
our own habits but like you guys I can't
believe you that that the Commissioner
wants Mike Trout to be something that
he's not to be more I said that but I
said you know what you can't ask him to
be something he's not and he's not Jeter
because Jeter played in New York played
in the postseason dominated in the
postseason and he also dated you know
movie stars and you know models so he
was different
he's different than Mike Trout Mike
trout's the best player yes first of all
Jeter was the the thing about Jeter was
the exact same player in the postseason
he was the regular season right like
eating dominate his numbers are actually
exactly the same yes incredible moment
yes he didn't really clutch but like
look all of these things were being
critical of is basically a Mike trout's
team good he's in the second team in LA
that's it and by the way like the
difference in the difference in him and
Harper he's having arguably the his best
year of his career Harper's team is they
have about the same record but he
they're a disaster because he's
surrounded by lay more talent and they
can't wait wait we're on the same side
with Trout
I I was surprised the Commissioner used
that stronger language to basically say
to Mike Trout I need something from you
I just said I can't ask Mike Trout to be
something he's not he's a great player
wonderful player but he doesn't have the
it that you find with some of these
other players where you tuned it the
tune in factor when you watch a game you
know that Mike is great well I I guess
maybe there may be the critique is of
the Commissioner now
even understanding his own sport nice
harbor doesn't have a tune in factor you
know how mookie betts is having an
unbelievable year do you think anybody
outside of Boston New York knows who
Mookie Betts is they just don't that's
it that's baseball it has nothing to do
with anybody's personality has to do
with the sport they know heartburn
Dunham Doug they know Harper did snow
Harper they do get snow trout any kid it
plays baseball in those trout and
anybody says otherwise
I got a kid who plays baseball everybody
knows trap well but he plays baseball in
California and you're an angel fan I
mean if they walk down if they walk down
the street if they walk down the street
in New York Bryce Harper and Mike Trout
wait New York sebassis the New York's a
baseball town it's not really I would
say they do know who Mike Schadt is no
no no dude he's been two-time all-star
MVP he's been an MVP like if you don't
know is like you know I just I think the
sport doesn't know what they are and
what their limitations are and how they
break through like Bryce Harper the
whole look and the attitude in the
persona yeah okay I get that but I mean
you could go through all of baseball
stars and their that no one knows who
they are if this is not you know their
this is not solely a Mike Trout problem
this is a baseball we you're trying to
create an argument when there is not an
argument there I'm with you on
I can't ask Mike Trout to be something
he's not I don't think it's fair for the
Commissioner to single him out like that
we're in agreement I think what it is is
he's reacting to there's an article in
The Washington Post about you know about
how Mike baseball has a Mike Trout
problem and I think they've
misidentified the problem right there
identifying symptoms and it's not the
problem the problem is baseball and how
baseball in like look it's baseball's
job to market Mike Trout not Mike
trout's job well you know what would
help though Doug is if he plays in the
postseason that that's that's where
people notice you that's when people
talk about you that's where you make
your career the postseason versus the
Yankees or the Red Sox I would agree I
mean like look I got 11 pitchers on the
DL and they are the second team in LA
there's just there's no other way
there's no other way to explain explain
why nobody pays attention to them but
you know like I think the crazy part
about it is
his energy in a game you can you can
feel it you go to an angel game and you
just like this dude is differently
special he plays a great joy the stuff
you talked about with judge when you
drowned in the basis like that's how
Mike Trout plays on a daily basis
he does everything every way you'd want
it to be dudes married there's no
nonsense and instead of trying to change
him make what he does more about who you
are that's how baseball should want
their players to act so other thing I
wanted to tell you was so so kawaai and
DeRozan yeah essentially they
contributed the same amount in the
playoffs last year four for each of
their teams correct well DeRozan at
least played fairly early he's still
plum he's still played I hadn't quit on
his team he didn't quit on us - yeah
look the Kauai thing is fascinating I I
would guess though the Toronto is going
to sit there and take a chance and see
you then get out of him but the truth is
they hated that DeRozan contract and
they wanted out and if they can't resign
Kauai they could flip him or he walks
and they can use that they can find a
way to use that salary space and and
start over I just think they thought
they topped out with DeRozan and they
they feel like they needed a change and
you take a shot at Kauai the crazy thing
is NBA guys love Toronto that's like a
top-five City on every NBA guys list
they go to trial like dude I could do
this that's the fascinating thing that
we feel like it's basketball Siberia and
it probably is to Kauai because he wants
to be in LA but to most any other NBA
player they they freaking love Toronto
yeah but they love visiting what have
you heard a free agent go hey I'm uh I'm
going to Toronto like I love visiting
Toronto and that's what they do they
love visiting Toronto and why wouldn't
you love it but I'm not hearing free
agents going yep got my short list here
Toronto is on it
no that's look it's accurate and that's
what you have that's what all these
other markets have to do all these other
non New York and LA and Miami markets
have to do them and I guess Houston
because it taxes and it's warm in the
winter but I think a lot of this move
is is about the DeRozan contract we're
in it's about they think they can keep
quiet I agree and I if I'm Toronto I'm
waiting for magic to call and say all
right you want him what are you gonna
give us can you give us something close
to what you know you were gonna give San
Antonio I would absolutely on Toronto I
turn it around
I know it's summer league famous but if
you saw Josh Hartnett you're watching
the Lakers does you're texting me about
how much you love speak like Josh Hart
became untradable last week and a half
you were the one who's saying I'm
overreacting to Josh Hart I love Josh
Hart you know what they got a good I
never texted you that I never said you
were over here I think you drunk text me
about Josh Hart or something like that I
get an amazing that people were you go
back a month ago and we were talking
about this trade like yeah Sterling's
Josh Hart who cares Owen Brandon Ingram
maybe Swain Kuzma and now you're sitting
there going like wait second Josh Hart
might be the starting to guard you know
you got Brandon Ingram was only twenty
years old you got kind of Cruz and I'm
like maybe you don't want a tree all
right all right all right I gotta go I
gotta go okay thank you bye love you
that's Doug Doug needs to do some cardio
or something go to a spin class or
something there for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]